okay hello everyone welcome hope you're
having a good day uh this stream is
supposed to start in I think two minutes
they said it wasn't quite on one o'clock
but we are expecting
a reveal
let me close that
of the Super Mario Bros movie
which I am
so curious about
like the casting announcement I think
that most people had the same response
where we were like I'm sorry what uh uh
what
here it is
I just want to know what they're gonna
make him sound like I just can't even
imagine I'm very curious
hello everyone I'm Shigeru Miyamoto as
we previously mentioned in today's
Nintendo Direct we'll reveal the first
trailer for The Super Mario Brothers
animated movie for the very first time
this Nintendo Direct is also being
broadcast simultaneously at New York
Comic-Con let's go New York Comic-Con
today lots of people around the world
are playing Mario games
thank you all so much
finally the world of Super Mario
Brothers will become an animated movie
we've been working on this movie
together with Chris melodandre what do
you mean finally for a long time we're
not going to pretend this hasn't
happened before come on now all the way
through production
the time flew by as we were having fun
figuring out how to depict the Super
Mario characters and world
now I'd like to hear from Chris San my
good friend and great partner for the
movie Chris song let's bring him in
Chris San
thank you Miyamoto song I think it was
going to be Chris Pratt but still that's
a weird choice and the entire
illumination crew of artists when I tell
you that producing the Super Mario
Brothers movie with you and your team at
Nintendo has been an absolute privilege
our crew is filled with Mario fanatics
and they're bringing the very best of
their talent to this film every day he's
taking a bit too seriously next week we
complete animation
we're knee-deep into lighting and
compositing composer bro you could say
this with a bit more
I think he's been working hand in hand
with Koji kondo to integrate classic
themes from the game into the film score
miyamoto-san it's been over seven years
since we first started talking about
making this movie together
and it is thrilling to finally be here
to show the very first look at footage
with Mario fans at Nintendo Direct and
at New York Comic-Con
miyamoto-san shall we go ahead and
introduce some of our cast
okay Chris son now I'll introduce two of
the stars from this movie
both of them love Nintendo games and
made this into a really fun movie are
you ready yeah
growing up man I spent hours of my life
stomping
Koopas
in the original Mario Brothers arcade
game at my local laundromat it's so
weird looking at this dude it's Mario
it's so weird I mean maybe years of my
life uh it's it's an honor truly to be
able to speak to the man who created
those memories for me
and it's it's an honor to work alongside
it's been a lifelong dream of mine to
become Warrior has it um
that that dream like all dreams faces
one critical challenge
as in the film
I must face off against
an utterly ruthless scene stealer every
great hero needs a diabolical enemy and
I promise you I could not have been
paired with the more perfect King of the
Koopas
Bowser
and my friend the Great
and hilarious
supremely Talented Mr Jack Black Jack
Black is a thank you
it's such a wild cost time for us to
make this moment all about me
while you've been dreaming about playing
Mario I've been preparing look at all
this coopa muscle that packed on and
this flowing Mane doesn't just appear
overnight do you have any idea how long
it took me to learn how to breathe fire
I had to go learn it from Gene Simmons
of Kiss
and all this hard work's been worth it
though I am so proud to have been able
to collaborate with you and miyamoto-san
as well as the entire Nintendo and
illumination team on this cinematic
experience one that will make its mark
on Mario fandom forever definitely much
love
I have walked to Jack Black before and
he was wonderful thank you Chris Sun
Jackson really nice guy all right then
thank you all for waiting let's press
the start button let's go
but the northern lights in there lovely
beautiful
it's
darker than I expected okay that's
interesting
open the gates
oh that's good
foreign
do you yield
I do not
he's really good at Bowser not that we
didn't think he would be but it's like
the voice he's doing is great
it's already weird it's already weird
oh he looks different they made him look
more
Pixar what is
oh
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
here we come he's doing Italian
did he just say Mushroom Kingdom Here We
Come
foreign
oh no
oh no
I want to thank all of you for being
part of this oh my God and we're excited
to share even more footage in the coming
months looking forward to it too
what do you think will happen during
Mario's Adventure
production of the movie is going well
holy crap like with any Nintendo game
we're working on the finishing touches I
hope you're looking forward to the next
trailer
it'll be a great experience watching the
Super Mario Brothers movie in movie
theater I can't believe it
you'll get to see the Mushroom Kingdom
on the big screen look closely and
you'll spot things in all sorts of
places this film can be enjoyed by
people of all ages so I hope you'll get
to a movie theater and cheer for Mario
that's all for today
we'll see you next spring in movie
theaters thank you
all right I um
you know
do you know what I mean you know what
I'm saying
uh
I actually thought the opening scene was
good I think Jack Black as Bowser is
great I like the humor there the
animation is really nice it doesn't look
just like a video game which would have
been an easy thing to do it does look
like a little bit more Pixar
um I even like the humor with the Mario
Tootsie
uh and it does suit toad as a character
with the screaming I imagine Nintendo
has worked really hard to maintain the
authenticity of these characters that's
obviously super important to them it's
their literal mascot
but
Mario Chris Pratt Mario I don't know
what we expected okay I don't know that
anybody expected it to sound incredible
but somehow seeing it come out of
Mario's face
it's just weird man
he's a good actor he's a good actor
it's not like he can't do the job it's
just really weird and it's like maybe
they chose somebody who's a little bit
too iconic
um
like he's been such a leading man even
from Parks and Rec while he wasn't a
leading man he was such a like a scene
stealing character
and then he goes on to Guardians of the
Galaxy Galaxy I don't know why I
stumbled on that one and Jurassic and
it's like
it's very hard not to just picture Chris
Pratt
um and I really didn't expect him to
just be doing an Italian accent
it's really strange I okay let's just
watch that a little bit again if we can
find it where would it be
I don't know how it directs
function okay it's right at the end
you can just start
here
because that just sounds like a grown
man
what is this place
because even though you can hear he's
doing it a little bit what is this place
it's not completely normal Chris Pratt
he's trying to Mario
oh I'm sorry a big fan of time it's
perfectly I like that Mario
Mushroom King
[Music]
thank you
it looks also re-watching that second
part where I didn't really catch it the
first time because I was just shrieking
at Chris Pratt
um it looks like it's really
action-packed I don't know like again
what I expected but
this looks like it's got fun and it's
got action which is generally going to
be a great animated film uh as long as
you've got heart in there too which is
very hard to convey from a trailer
I think it's just going to be very hard
for a lot of people who've played any
Mario game which has got to be you know
millions and millions of people millions
and millions and millions and millions
of people
to get past
the Mario
it's strange
having Pratt makes sorry this is just
someone from chat sekibo said having
Pratt makes me think they went into
production not being fully confident in
the product and wanted the extra
marketing draw
I would think it probably is about
making sure you have a really big name
attached to the character gear which
like I think doesn't work for Mario
because he the way we know his voice to
work I I don't doubt that they were
confident though I don't know that it
would have been that I think that that's
probably a separate thing
Jack Black is Bowser and a little bit of
Charlie days Luigi I think at St but I
can't get used to Mario's voice oh did
we hear Charlie day is Luigi
I just gotta go back to like here
Mushroom Kingdom that's Chris Pratt
foreign
okay yeah you're just kind of hearing
him scream I mean Charlie day will carry
it because he's so funny that it's like
it adds Ridiculousness whereas I don't
picture Chris Pratt that way even though
obviously he is funny he's largely only
played comedic roles or at least that
I'm aware of
um
it's not comical in the way that Charlie
day is I don't know dude it's just weird
I think doing Charles Martin it would
have been really hard to uh icy snacks
said that in chat
because
he's also Wonderful by the way I've met
him too and he's he was one of the
nicest people I've ever met I I spent a
whole night with him without realizing
that he was Mario and then when he left
someone was like you know that that's
the voice of Mario and I was like what
he's a really nice guy
um I think that
that is gonna be
the way that he voices Mario in the
games is not akin to a full film where
he has to be a full realized character I
think that it did need to be different
potentially he could have done it but
that would have been a struggle I think
or it would have been strange
and would have had a weird impact on
games going forward potentially
it it had to have been a really hard
Choice
um
it's a bit too close to Ryan Reynolds is
Pikachu it's gonna take time to get over
see I really liked Ryan Reynolds as
Pikachu again I think because of the
tone of the film
I don't know
it's just uh
it's strange I do think it's a pretty
good trailer again I really like the
pacing of that trailer I like what it
shows it looks really pretty it looks
darker than I expected which is cool
um
and it's again it's not like I I thought
I was going to go into this and have my
mind changed so maybe we're all just
gonna take some time and it's gonna be
fine it's just really strange
it's really strange
uh all right
um I gotta get back to work
I think you all for joining me for
um
whatever this was
you know I just sort of